hey guys now for most of you that's been
following me over these last few years
you already know that i would probably
be
bold already if it wasn't for the irish
store
and also for healthy foods that promote
hair growth
so in this video i want to share my
knowledge and i'm going to show you the
10
best foods that will promote your hair
growth let's get right to it
[Music]
all right now if you're here for the
first time my name is daniel and welcome
to my channel
now you need to know that there are four
big things
that determine your hair growth what is
it well it's your age
your health genetics and lastly your
diet
now you already know you can't really do
anything about your age and
your genes right but you can do
something
about your health and your diet so let's
take a look at the best
10 foods that will promote your hair
growth
spinach and also other leafy greens
spinach is awesome
for so many reasons it's one of the best
vegetables that you can eat
it's loaded with iron folate and also
vitamin a
and c which of course makes your hair
grow better
lentils it's great because it's rich in
iron protein which of course is good for
cell growth
and that includes your hair follicles
it's got vitamin b
and that helps your body to make new
cells and strengthens
your hair
[Music]
berries berries are packed with
antioxidants and vitamins that can
promote a hair growth
let me give an example strawberries
they're full of vitamin c
and of course vitamin c helps collagen
production
and iron absorption which helps hair
growth
eggs they're cheap they're healthy and
you need it because they are full of
protein
and guess what else is full of protein
your hair follicles is made up of
protein
and if you don't get enough you might
experience hair loss
eggs also contain biotin which of course
help your hair to grow
faster fatty fish
my favorite is tuna and salmon and i
actually
love it to catch tuna myself and eat it
fresh fatty fish is a great source of
omega-3 fatty acids
and that helps your hair to grow thicker
and faster
next up is sweet potatoes sweet potatoes
are awesome because they're cheap in
most countries and if you eat it you'll
get a lot of vitamin a
why is this good because vitamin a helps
in sebum production
why is that important well because sebum
will keep your hair moisturized and
protected from breakage
nuts i'm nuts about nuts and they're
awesome
just like fatty fish because they
contain that healthy fat that your body
needs
that your hair needs healthy nuts like
almonds and walnuts are
full of nutrients like vitamin e vitamin
b and
zinc it's great for hair growth
[Music]
next is whole grains oh man there are a
few things in this world that i love as
much as that
fresh whole wheat bread coming out of
the oven you smell it you eat it
nothing beats it and it also helps your
hair growth
so healthy whole grain whole wheat bread
and pasta
they'll give you natural biotin which of
course promotes hair growth
[Music]
sweet peppers eat more sweet peppers to
get more vitamin a and vitamin c
which by now you already know helps your
hair to grow
faster and thicker
oysters another thing i love i know a
lot of guys don't like eating oysters
but it's great
because you get a lot of zinc from it
and that helps hair growth
and its repair cycle
now just because you watch until the end
i'm going to give you a bonus tip
a bonus tip is avocados it's got a
healthy fat
vitamin e and that of course will help
your hair growth
now if you want to know more about good
supplements and other hair growth
products that actually work
check out the video description down
below i've added it in there for you so
you can go and check them out
now stick around watch some of my other
videos here and i'll see you there and
always remember
life is short so don't waste it cheers
guys